[Music]
coming at you [__] on these
birthday party
[Music]
man
a couple different weeds for you
[__] today
you got the stars of debt we got liquid
ass you know ya always Placido Domingo
with his mother oh yeah
[Music]
oh [__] the chemicals are coming out
[__]
[Laughter]
you guys thought we wanted [__]
sabbatical the church never goes on
sabbatical seven days a week
[__] 24/7 we're ready tonight we got a
tremendous night we got wedding cake
[__] delicious
we got JJ Abrams is making up gay [__]
zunzi's [__] and we got as usual the
heartbeat of organization perennial
[__] og also will come in and
deep like Capone with the stars of death
[Music]
[Laughter]
you dare enter this house [__]
[__] with us on a Wednesday night you
might as well go to your ladies night
eat some ribs at Buffalo Wild Wings cuz
they ain't gonna get no benefit here
tellingly silently science already
lookin family bond little weak still
goes to Lisa yet ponder the [__] weak
understand me
for you [__] half RVs out there here
we go we're gonna open up a bung bung of
JJ you understand me why cuz that's how
we roll up in handle Wednesday night
[Music]
just disappear into the [__] night
understand me pilot to Bombardier oh
there you are
[Music]
what the [__] did people think you're
dealing some [__] okey doke over here
nothing no there's no reason to coffee
the lungs our trains already understand
me
we [__] around here tonight if you
thought it was gonna be that type of
night hang up now hang up now it's Lee's
birthday if we do this [__] when it's
not least birthday could you imagine
what we do want to is Lee's birthday
there you go stay right there
[__] there you go like a savage there
you go there you go there you go oh it's
some same training is training when you
want to be a green beret this is it you
got a joke yeah I bought I was a little
guy one time his eyeball popped out of
his head
we had a woman yeah walk 30 yards we
picked it up we took him to the house
when they wild up man he's got a
fucked-up eye but he's got his I
understand
[Music]
what the [__] was smoking this
[__]
it's Wednesday night put away the
susquehanna uncle Joey's here with his
trusted Goomba [__] the flying Jew
making it happen smoking sativas doin
edibles it's a birthday night we
celebrated at my house man my daughter
made us go get a cake his ship at least
wheeze birthday my friend we you know
[__] around like a dad loyalty [__] she
loves it who's ready for a bonding we
got two more laughter this [__] Jade
ain't no stopping when you're popping it
I'm saying the only people will stop
these amateurs that drink coffee and lay
all these claims they can't run with the
[__] savages yeah families wear boots
and you gotta believe me
[Music]
oh [__] nothing his last was believe me
Tina's sister Tevas men's I motive like
I told you sativas don't work on Uncle
Joe you got to show up early in the
morning with a sativa you're looking
good today Lee what the kettlebells
you put the [__] thing together
that's an ice-cream cake you know we do
it people just hear thee we're here for
you we don't want you going out there we
saw at birthday fun number two how old
the 20 years I was doing 14 apiece
[Music]
look at that beautiful burn right there
look at that smoke creeping while you're
sleeping this is why you control it
right there give it an extra book there
you go dr. balista
is I'm talking about this is it and you
want to celebrate your birthday with
eight arms Harvey homos on a [__]
restaurant eat your dinner make him
believe
oh we love the red wine that's a soldier
right there training that's how you
celebrate your [__] birthday not with
eight guys on the dinner look at us like
jerk bumps get the [__] out of here
two gentlemen doing [__] bang outs
till one of us dies that's what we're
doing today that's a birthday right
there old school the shed North Bergen
New Jersey with a villo bodies
everywhere if you passed out pick a spot
[__] got ain't got nothin dude
it's all about you
God could only help you God can't help
you but he can only help you who help
themselves
oh [__]
yeah fairies wear boots and you gotta
believe me let's do some wedding cake
[__] get the party started here oh did
you say stars how can you have a
birthday without no [__] star we got
stars do you coming look at these when I
come connected this is good luck
it's like stepping that [__] you got to
go right to the [__] Hindu and then
get a pick three lottery ticket you know
I'm saying
so did you get well these two lucky ones
that's like stepping on dog [__] you got
a right run to the [__] the 7-eleven and
get yourself a [__] lottery ticket
for my sis Junior please these are two
connected with a tail
you know what these duties they put in a
different plan but this point at night I
will give a Frenchman [__]
oh the slow-motion bong it now we got
for Philippe oh it's a wise thing I
wouldn't expect people you want [__]
in here and people hanging out I don't
do that [__] no man I was nobody but my
[__] family right there
[Music]
I feel unhappy I feel so sad I still got
some blood snots I would show them
people I like it too much I don't want
to lose the viewership my busting out of
[__] slaughter death well there's no
surgery snotty but hey you here for
Lee's birthday and that means the world
to me you understand me Lee's even four
stars oh [__] and you came right in time
for some wedding cake you see you're
lucky people you people are nice [__]
people that's why I do this she think I
wanna have with a bunch of [__] fake
[__] I got you [__] I'm as
strong as that we understand as long as
I got you [__] on my back even
if it's just three is watching that's
all we need
oh my god people at wish you could see
this wedding cake how it comes and its
original form did you [__] just
[__] you know I'm trying to tell you
people here listen
call your boss tomorrow time you quit in
two weeks come to California cut this
[__] you know you want to come on in how
you gonna die without living in
California
listen start from scratch come on e and
do temple temp work your [__]
soldiers the birthday boy with some
wedding cake no I just put it there for
[__] celebration sake
well I thought the mouse's me I got
something I got I gave the muscle yeah
that's wedding cake right there perfect
in love together
keep the write that keep right
keep it within there you go there you go
three three down eleven to go is [__]
I'm going through changes that's
tremendous I was a tremendous bong hit
only Syed I'm gonna even finish it flung
because that's the type of [__]
you're dealing ready you bad mother you
Signet go Joey what the [__] I'm telling
you what the [__] people it's over these
fake okie Dokes you people oh we love
Jared cuz you're [__] suckers
we got the flavor here and it's [__]
you Goomba the flying Judah we don't
give a [__] Jack we got one from the
grave what a banana peel it's bondage
for Jesus bondage for Satan bong hits
for black lines matters we do it all
here [__] who said one more bong
hit you wait crazier just get we got 11
more to go
we got a long night this please birthday
party how would you celebrate please
birthday fun we got the black chick
coming she gonna fight in his mouth
she's believed me for two weeks straight
and she had a bag of prunes this morning
she's ready to go so all my days
I filled with tears wish I could go back
and change these years going to change
it it's over people what are you gonna
do we're good to go watch call right now
for what you got uncle Joey we tell them
what this weed smells this is poison
[Music]
you know us people it's a birthday
Wednesday I have an anniversary Tuesday
July 28 1982 I had to put some rain in
that place today [__] 34 years ago
somebody got confused and [__] around
with uncle Joey like you know and I had
to take that ass to the hoop Jackie I'm
saying until this day
she thought she was cute but he said I'm
saying
don't [__] with nobody we don't know
what the animal you're dealing with no
[__] with
[Music]
sorry about that a bud flew over on top
of the record player it happens when
you're in an environment like this
you're gonna get hit with mud or spit
with the cervix I start a little lonely
office stuff he's just sitting there all
by himself
i twinkles one you can open your eyes
you'll be fine here we go
[Music]
my life the first three buns are
elementary oh yeah it's the [__] ones
at third barn but get your lungs it's
like 20 but it's a Claudia
most people are dead by then but that's
when you start burning fat at the
twenty-minute book funny thing goes for
fun let's do this [__]
go
[Music]
is it clock fix this [__] I've seen
your high
here we go [__]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the new basement in
[__] scans [__] don't know what
you're about you bad [__]
what's up baby boys let's go League we
got to go tip-top Magoo
this is the one that [__] ready
[Music]
they gonna Skookum against suck let's go
hey you gonna see that much that little
smoke on the bottle is the one you need
to get what is that what you think a
little baby hits let's go
what's your finger did he go is [__]
there you go see
like a soldier people we're here at the
church headquarters
you know we sold our soul for
rock'n'roll this is it ladies and
gentlemen we not molest long I'll have
much coffee
come on what the [__] him I don't know
passages I can't quote no history is I
don't know know Confucius all I know
it's cracking jokes of my dog over here
right yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
I will get this party [__] started
here enough with these bonnets but you
people started we just want to do a
bottle so you talked us into four or
five [__] bottles they can't keep
doing this to us people looking poorly
he's oh [__] children of the great you
might be doing along it this is it
listen to music talking stupidity with
your friends I don't know man beats
going to some club and trying to lie the
people of the VIP area and get a 15-mile
of bottles this is me two other dudes
maybe a friend I don't know some [__]
on nerves 22 food to Lutz or the best
weed out there a couple [__] cookies
something good on the screen we can do
this all [__] night look like USA
remember that show years ago night
flight
we can do this on Friday night mainly
get some chicken here that you like
Kate's out of [__] town would you sit
here all night watch cable TV coming
smoking dope with you as a family
[Music]
revolution in their minds children's got
the launch
[Music]
it's always here [__] so is it
always prepared let's say there's an
earthquake I can't leave here we got
water we got water we got [__] beer
we don't have no office supplies either
take a paperclip and shove it up your
ass we got rolling papers we got THC
juice we got THC vapor liquid CID I mean
you know we got it going on in this
[__] except you ain't here
[Music]
we are CBD oil we got tremendous refill
we are rolling papers we got a bomb the
pipe
we got a pin we got nicotine gum you
know listen I'll take you from A to Z
like a [__] you don't even know what
hit you
you'll be sitting in one minute next let
you listen to [__] you are following
the live out whatever the [__] it is the
double live out all right
listen thank you for the [__] hi thank
you for hanging out with us you know we
love youse all our goodies like balls
you see those eyeballs he had my sign as
we came over here four or five years ago
you can see the white but that shit's
demolition by the day understand me
we love you [__] the church
tomorrow night flappers the yoo-hoo room
don't [__] around no expectations I just
got a bunch of [__] opening lines and
no punchlines if you're into that [__]
come on down I love you thank you for
[__] being family and for always
having our backs gon stay black
[Music]